yo it's like we say women got the
unrealistic expectations and some of
them do but ain't nobody got more
unicorn fairy tale Dora the Explorer
expectations of the opposite sex than us
men again some women do expect a man to
be six feet tall and make six figures
and have a six pack abs and that's
unrealistic for most men but I know like
10 dudes already that fit into that
category all you got to do is have a
good job and some good genetics and you
straight but look at us like how what do
we expect of a woman she got to be a
virgin but she got to be a freak she
gotta pay half the bills but she got to
do 100 of the cleaning the cooking the
child raisin she gotta be exhausted from
all of that you know all the cooking and
washing the cleaning and all that good
stuff and still be horny enough to meet
our sexual needs and get a good night's
rest but also wake up in the middle of
the night in case we want some head and
a turkey sandwich that ain't it she also
gotta give birth to all our babies
because you know we gotta have that
Legacy but then she can't have no
stretch marks and she gotta lose that
baby weight in 30 days or less and and
then she got to do it while fighting
postpartum depression by herself because
we're gonna tell her she have an
attitude or something like that because
all we thinking about is we ain't got no
vagina in the last six weeks that she
got to take the hill that ain't it then
she can get older but she can't look
older otherwise we're gonna say that
she's falling off like the list goes on
but just tell me something how many
women do you know that fit into that
category none
so who really got the unrealistic
expectations
sir it's so offensive
goodies are we watched another one no no
we'll go back to the next one later it's
like did you did you have those
unrealistic expectations yeah finger
like when your wife was pregnant and
your wife had those children like are
you just saying all the things that you
did while your wife was going through
all this I don't hear God guys really
demand that high of expectations
that genuinely expects a virgin I I
don't know one
I mean I think some of them are like I'd
be nice but I don't think men are that
delusional no we live in 2022 wait
there's a handful of women
may I say one thing I'll just put my
hand up man I'll say one thing this guy
said just have a job and good genetics
like that's something that you can pick
you know pick your genetics Derek
like what are you talking about oh I
know I know at least 10 guys just
because you're six foot four Derek it
doesn't mean that that's just something
that's handed out like that exactly this
guy's an idiot Ralph like what the vast
majority of men are under six foot so
saying just have good genetics I broke
like what kind of world do you live in
bro like I didn't know when you was born
you could just say oh I would like to be
six foot four like bro like it doesn't
go like that bro so like he's already
leading women down a road of failure
because he's trying to make it out like
oh yeah you know these unrealistic
expectations or did this small minority
oh that's easy to find there's there's
loads of guys like that no it's not but
I think everyone needs to be more
realistic and again just just like Jess
said a lot of the things he's talking
about bro you slept with a side chick or
a couple side chicks behind your woman's
back and you had a kid so how dare you
talk about other guys bro
that is it's actually he makes my blood
boil like I swear like he makes my blood
boil like he's just saying anything and
he's actually making the dating Market
harder for everyone not just guys for
everybody because now women are walking
around with these delusional
expectations because Derek Jackson said
yeah that yeah actually that makes sense
no it doesn't make sense bro
you know what I'm saying like it's a
joke thing and what percent of guys even
make six figures it's like less than ten
percent yeah he was saying like oh yeah
just get a job bro like come on bro like
that's that's unrealistic absolutely
unrealistic
I don't know if you look
yeah he's he's uh he's a cool no that's
so offensive like I'm not a man but
obviously
obviously there's
a normal reasonable man good man and
he's saying oh yeah every man wants this
this and literally making women like
drumming up them their hatred for men
and so she would I guarantee you should
look out the window and be like yeah I
hate him like some random man
that's because of what you say yeah
because Derek Jackson says he knows at
least 10 guys that make six figures that
are over six foot so if you don't come
into that category then ah forget about
you when that could be her husband yeah
exactly what I'm saying she could be
happy and then the one thing he said
that was actually I just chuckled to he
said oh when um you want your woman to
have babies for you for your legacy
really truly like to be honest with you
it's usually women that push to have
kids more than guys bro really you know
what I'm saying I don't know about one
of my ex-girlfriends she wanted a kid
bad and I had to just stop sleeping with
her because I was scared she was gonna
do that you know what I'm saying so all
of that is a joke then he was like oh
yeah
um when when you have a kid for your man
he wants you to lose all the weight in
30 days or less brav what are you
talking about you now you're just making
up nonsense like you're just making up
stories bro like and again just like you
said it's gonna cause more of a division
between women because the women because
he's saying stuff that he knows women
want to hear extreme extreme dreams that
is going to make pump them up to feel
like yeah men are they are unreasonable
they're evil do you get what I'm saying
he's an idiot his normal is toxic
that's what it looks like to me like
what he uses as his examples are toxic
Behavior anyway and I'm realisticated
yeah he's appealing to women that are
having like they find it hard getting a
partner do you understand so and now
it's even harder if they're listening to
him it's ridiculous I don't think he
really cares what he's saying at this
well at that point even now because he
still makes videos yeah so and they keep
following they keep subscribing maybe
not as much as they used to but you
still have people following somebody
that
just actually tells you just what you
want to hear or what women want to hear
because his main
his main
his main audience is women
um
do you think that the simps are part of
the problem with all the delusional
women these days
Sims yes Sims absolutely
absolutely man because if it wasn't for
The Sims here
like it kind of enables the delusion in
a lot of the modern women today to get
what I'm saying if it was just like
playing black and white okay men like
like these type of women they like these
type of traits they have these kind of
expectations which in my opinion I think
men are quite simple and easy to please
yeah like right it will kind of just be
plain sailing like women would know what
to do men would know what to do like
it's just like men know we women want to
be protected and and provided for men
know that do you get what I'm saying
there's not really no pushback with that
but in today's time you've got Sims that
will will come out here and be like oh
yeah you got to do all of this and no
matter what the woman's doing you still
need to protect and provide for her even
though she's not a traditional woman do
you think modern women deserve to be
courted
no one deserves nothing breath
that's what I'm saying from
yeah what do you think
I don't know
I don't record it
all like modern women too
yeah deserve
I think they should why not
but deserved though that's the that's
the key word no because because I think
like as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible